[Música]
este domingo los candidatos a la
presidencia de Brasil se encontrarán
para un debate de Cara a la segunda
vuelta del 30 de octubre y para ello
Tendremos una serie de informes
especiales sobre el contexto en el cual
se celebran estos comicios
Estados Unidos y Canadá enviaron ayuda a
la policía de Haití para combatir a los
grupos criminales que han venido
bloqueando el flujo de alimentos y
combustible una situación que ha
empeorado la crisis humanitaria que vive
el país
México empezó a recibir a los migrantes
venezolanos deportados desde Estados
Unidos que han ingresado al país desde
la frontera Sur la medida los dejan
desventaja teniendo en cuenta que
Washington sí recibirá a miles de estos
ciudadanos que ingresen por ahí
Hola y bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Brasil este domingo los candidatos a la
presidencia se verán cara a cara antes
de la segunda vuelta el 30 de octubre
como parte de nuestra serie de informes
especiales esta vez les presentamos a
los grupos que apoyan al presidente Yair
bolsonaro quien Busca la reelección se
trata de la coalición de los tres B
balas Biblia y buey que se refieren
respectivamente a los Pro armas
evangélicos y Gigantes de la agronegocio
respotencias ultraconservadoras que ya
se habían Unido en 2018 para darle la
victoria en aquellas elecciones cuatro
años después estos grupos siguen
caminando al lado del actual mandatario
los detalles con lea huge
las tres B simbolizan el Trío
ultraconservador que sigue siendo el
núcleo de la base electoral de James
Durante este mandato el ictus salen
Gómez freitas se sintió valorado por el
presidente ultraderechista
recuerde una época en la que ningún
político presentó ningún respeto a la
policía a las familias que perdieron a
sus policías
conozco a Yahir Mesías bolsonaro de esa
época era un simple diputado federal
pero iba a los funerales de nuestros
colegas rendía homenajes decir veía al
policía como un ciudadano
el ex policía se define como Padre de
Familia conservador Pro armas y terror
de la izquierda y votará para allí por
su narró el 31
tal como Marisa ruso Pérez es una
profesora jubilada y evangélica teme que
si el izquierdista Lula vuelve al poder
se imponga una educación contraria a sus
creencias
tenemos principios cristianos así que
por ejemplo el aborto es algo anticristo
cristiano
preocupación por lo que nos preocupa si
un candidato que piensa así se pone en
una posición de Liderazgo y nos impone
esto es muy difícil
una derrota de Jair bolsonaro iría
también en contra de los intereses de
Carlos moresco productor agropecuario
después de un gobierno que favoreció
como ningún otro a lo largo de negocio
soy una persona Leal a los que son
leales a los valores y principios en los
que creo y nuestro presidente tiene
estos valores morales y sabe valorar
tanto a los pobres como a los ricos
Por eso creo que merece tener otros
cuatro años para poder concluir el
trabajo que se propuso hacer en el país
el agro negocio tiene un el poder de
presión política por sus números sus
diputados y senadores y aporta casi el
28% del pib de Brasil
por otro lado en Río de Janeiro los
ciudadanos de las favelas y barrios más
pobres de la ciudad Se decantan
mayoritariamente por el izquierdista
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva para el
balotaje todo a pesar de que Río de
Janeiro es un estado bastión del
bolsonarismo los detalles a continuación
aquí en rasiña la Favela más grande de
Río de Janeiro la mayoría ya han hecho
su apuesta para la segunda vuelta de las
elecciones el ex presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva
no hizo nada por mí al contrario hizo
las cosas más difíciles para las
personas de menores ingresos no mejoro
las cosas Aunque la gente diga que Lula
es un ladrón en los tiempos de Lula
podíamos comprar un televisor mejor
mejor
en la primera vuelta Lula ganó en La
Barriada con más del 65% de los votos al
igual que en la mayoría de favelas de la
ciudad como vidigal mareo alemao todo a
pesar de que el estado de Río de Janeiro
es fuertemente bolsonarista al final la
gente pasa hombre y solo los pobres
ayudan a los pobres Y es que las favelas
como rosina son un reflejo del perfil de
los votantes del ex mandatario de
izquierdas ya que según la última
encuesta de Data [__] los más pobres
las mujeres los afro y los más jóvenes
se decantan por el líder del partido de
los trabajadores estamos pagando nueve
dólares por un kilo de carne con tres
piezas y van a votar por bolsonaru en
serio es Lula l bolsonaro tiene apoyos
en las favelas pero su popula ha bajado
por su gestión de la pandemia y el
repunte del hambre factores que
empujaron a personas como Antonio dos
Santos peluquero de rosina ha decantarse
por Lula en estas elecciones a pesar de
haber votado por bolsionaron en el 2018
el tipo parecía que se tomaba la
pandemia en broma
niños muriendo mujeres perdiendo a sus
maridos hombres perdiendo a sus esposas
y a él no le importaba
ahí durante su campaña Lula ha prometido
a los pobres como la mayoría de la
población de rosina que alejará el
hambre de sus vidas y a propósito de
estas elecciones los invitamos a que se
conecten este domingo desde las 18 horas
de Bogotá quito y Lima con nuestro
especial de noticias con motivo de este
debate entre los candidatos a la
presidencia de Brasil Luis Ignacio Lula
da Silva y el presidente Yair bolsonar
cambiamos de tema vamos a Haití que
recibió este sábado ayuda proveniente de
Estados Unidos y Canadá para combatir la
ola de inseguridad que azota al país se
trata de vehículos tácticos y blindados
además de otros suministros entregados a
la Policía Nacional con los que
reforzarán su lucha contra las bandas
criminales que han estado bloqueando el
flujo de asistencia humanitaria que se
necesita de manera crítica de acuerdo
con cifras de la ONU más de 4 millones
de personas se enfrentan inseguridad
alimentaria aguda
México Comenzó desde este miércoles a
recibir a los migrantes venezolanos
deportados desde Estados Unidos como
parte de una nueva política de
Washington que restringe el ingreso de
este grupo de personas que lleguen de
manera regular por tierra Ciudad Juárez
junto con otras cuatro urbes como
Tijuana ya albergan a estos migrantes y
la medida los deja más vulnerables y en
situación de desventaja
estos migrantes transitaron miles de
kilómetros a través de fronteras trochas
y selvas cuando creían Ver el final La
pesadilla comenzó de nuevo no se dirigen
a nosotros
de pertenencias y yayos en ningún
momento nos dijeron que ustedes van a
ser deportados nada solamente nos
sacaron y Nos llevaron allá el llanto
dio paso a la incertidumbre después de
pisar suelo estadounidense estos
venezolanos fueron deportados a Tijuana
México dando inicio al programa del
gobierno estadounidense pactado con las
autoridades mexicanas para frenar el
creciente flujo migratorio que llega por
tierra
a todas las autoridades a que por favor
que vean este caso no sabemos qué hacer
estamos en el Limbo Estados Unidos no
nos da una solución y México tampoco la
ruta que puede durar meses se inicia en
Venezuela la mayoría cruzan el peligroso
tapón del Darién fronteras selvática
entre Colombia y Panamá si lo logran al
periplo continúa por todo Centroamérica
hasta el norte de México donde las
mafias les ayudan a cruzar a Estados
Unidos Washington señaló que ofrecerá
estatus legal a 24.000 venezolanos
siempre y cuando éstos lleguen por vía
aérea y cuenten con un patrocinante
marginando así a los migrantes más
vulnerables porque estamos viviendo una
locura aquí todo no sabemos qué hacer
Tenemos es hambre hermano en México aquí
en la frontera ahí sabe Ahí está puesta
al muro No hayamos que hacer estamos
jodidos no sabemos nos sacaron sin sin
decir mira está deportado si no fueran
deportados que me manden para Venezuela
un avión yo tuviera tranquilo en
Venezuela ya que me mande para Venezuela
pero Nos soltaron aquí en la frontera
qué hacemos ante muchos están llamando a
familiares y amigos que siguen en la
ruta hacia el norte para que paren su
tránsito y es que en lo que va de año
las autoridades fronterizas
contabilizaron más de 155.000 migrantes
venezolanos el triple que el año
anterior tal como se mencionaba en
nuestro reportaje anterior la mayoría de
estos migrantes cruzan el peligroso
tapón del Darién una frontera selvática
entre Colombia y Panamá solo Hace unos
días unas desgarradoras imágenes
publicadas por el New York Times dieron
cuenta de las difíciles condiciones a
las que se ven sometidas decenas de
miles de personas que transitan por este
inhóspito lugar con el objetivo de
llegar a alcanzar el sueño americano
previamente hablamos con Federico Ríos
El fotógrafo que logró capturar estos
momentos y quien nos habló sobre la
información que tienen estas personas
sobre el proceso migratorio que les
espera en países como México
algunas personas lo saben algunas
personas también que están cruzando en
este momento entre
Panamá y México lo saben y están ahí
preguntándose qué hacer sé que necoclí
hay un momento de crisis que se está
viviendo algunas personas se han
devuelto incluso desde capurganá que es
la puerta de entrada a la selva hacia
necoclí a todo esto es complejo Es
realmente la situación compleja Porque
eso los tomó por sorpresa es una una
norma que empieza a regir desde el
momento en el que Se expide y muchas
personas estaban sin aviso debe haber
personas que están en este momento
atravesando la selva que no tienen
acceso a internet o a un teléfono porque
allí no hay señal de nada durante varios
días y cuando salgan se van a enterar de
que de que esto sucedió hasta que ese
Informativo en francés 24 Gracias por
acompañarnos
[Música]